what if I told you that the main villain
in mha tomura shigaraki was actually
born quirkless and what if I also told
you that Deku wasn't born quirkless but
his real Quirk was stolen by all for one
when he was still a baby in fact we may
have been looking at deku's real quirk
in action since the very beginning of
the story but we just didn't know it
because it was being used by someone
else in this video I will break down
some of the most controversial theories
in mha that all fit together and could
actually be true I am willing to bet
that one of these theories is not only
true but that it's about to be revealed
in the manga very soon so let's get into
it you guys know how this works if you
enjoy rmha content and you want to see
more in the future leave a quick like
and comment right now and if you're one
of the over 50 of people who watch our
videos regularly but still haven't taken
the time to subscribe remember that
subscribing on YouTube is completely
free and it means I a lot in terms of
supporting the channel so do me a favor
and do it right now finally this video
will contain Boku no hero manga spoilers
so please proceed with caution you have
been warned for several years now
there's been a theory that tenko shimura
the young boy who eventually became the
villain tomorrow shigaraki was born
quirkless I've talked about this theory
in the past and other YouTubers talked
about it even before me including my
buddy zonin according to this Theory The
Quirk that tenko eventually manifests
Decay did not belong to him originally
and it was transferred onto him by the
villain all for one without the boy's
knowledge or consent this idea dates
back to chapter 235 when the backstory
of tenko shimura is finally revealed in
a flashback we see that young tenko is
five years old and he still hasn't
manifested a quirk which would indicate
that he is actually quirkless that's
because everyone who is born with a
quirk manifested by the age of four and
not having a quirk after that time
normally means that you won't have a
quirk at all five-year-old tanko
desperately wanted to become my hero but
the odds were certainly stacked against
him for one thing there was a high
possibility that he was born quirkless
and for another his father kotaro
shimura absolutely forbade both of his
children to become Heroes I say both of
his children because tenko had an older
sister Hannah and the father wouldn't
even allow them to talk about heroes let
alone become Heroes themselves kotaro's
irrational hatred of Heroes stems from
his own childhood trauma kotaro is the
son of Nana shimura a pro-hero all
might's former master and the seventh
user of one for all little kotaro loved
his mother and was very close to her but
after his father and Nana's husband was
killed by All For One Nana was forced to
make a very difficult decision because
she was a one for all user she was a
constant Target for all for one and she
knew that the tragic death of her
husband would not be the end all for one
would continue going after her and her
family and her son kotaro would always
be in life-threatening danger as long as
he remained close to her Nana decided to
place her son into foster care and she
cut off all forms of communication with
him in order to prevent all for one from
tracking him down she also instructed
her two closest friends all might and
Gran Torino to cut off all contact with
kotaro as well Nana all might and Gran
Torino were all being targeted by all
for one and they could all assume that
they were always being watched by the
villains if any of them tried to contact
kotaro in any way there was a strong
possibility that all for one would get
word of it and this would lead to him
locating kotaro so in Nana's mind it was
either give up her son and never contact
him again or risk him being killed or
kidnapped by the villains in their
attempt to get to her she didn't want to
give up her son it was a deeply painful
decision for her but she thought that
this was the only way to keep him safe
her instincts were probably correct
because sometime later she herself was
killed by all for one in battle but not
before she was able to transfer one for
all to her successor Almighty however
little kotaro interpreted the situation
nation very differently and as he got
older he became more and more resentful
of his mother and of Heroes in general
he felt that his mother abandoned him
when he needed her the most he was very
young and impressionable and he had just
lost his father he needed his mother
more than ever and she just left and cut
off all contact with him even though she
only did this in order to keep him safe
kotaro believed that his mother chose
her career as a Pro Hero over him her
own son he never forgave her for this
and he developed a firm opinion that
heroes in general are selfish people who
neglect and abandon their families in
the pursuit of wealth Fame and Glory
when kotaro grew up and started a family
of his own he made it clear to them that
he disapproved of Heroes and that there
would be no mention of Heroes in their
home needless to say trying to become a
hero was absolutely forbidden but
becoming a hero is exactly what Young
tanko wanted and he would secretly go
out and play Hero when his father wasn't
around on one such day tenko was dropped
off at his home by a mysterious man
after the boys pretend heroics landed
him into some trouble the man who
dropped Deku off is shown in just a
single panel in chapter 235 and we don't
see his face this panel is small and
easily forgettable but it is actually
much more important than you think the
person who dropped tenko off is a large
man who wears a suit and a fedora this
very much fits the description of the
villain all for one at least before he
was severely injured by all might all
for one is a large man who often wears
suits and we also know that he liked to
combine his suits with Fedora hats and
how do we know this well over 100
chapters later in chapter 350 we see all
for one rescuing a severely injured Toya
Todoroki from the fire on sekoto peak in
this scene all for one is wearing a suit
and a fedora and he looks extremely
similar to the man who dropped little
tank off in chapter
235 after getting dropped off by that
mysterious man who is clearly all for
one tanko is colded by his father his
father was verbally and physically
abusive towards tenko especially
regarding tenko's dreams of becoming a
hero the shiz really hits the fan after
tenko and his sister Hana sneak into
their Father's Office in order to look
at a photo that his father had been
keeping there their unauthorized visit
to the office was actually Hannah's idea
and the photo in question was a photo of
a young kotaro hugging his mother Nana
who was wearing her hero costume at the
time this is how tenko found out that
his grandma had been a hero because his
father deliberately refused to share
that kind of information with him when
tenko asks his sister why she wanted to
show him the photo she says that she is
on his side and that she hopes that one
day the two of them can fall for my
brother sister hero team but when kotaro
finds out that his children snuck into
his office Hannah becomes scared and she
throws tenko under the bus even though
sneaking into the office was her idea
she blames tenko for everything she
tells her father that going inside was
her brother's idea kotaro then snaps at
tenko and proceeds to physically beat
him he also says that the woman in the
photo wasn't his grandmother but a
Monster who abandoned her own child
kotaro says that heroes are people who
hurt their own families in the name of
helping complete strangers and as he
says this he continues to beat tenko
what's more as kotaro is doing this
tanko's mother sister and both maternal
grandparents watching horror but they
don't actually do anything to stop
kotaro they just allow it to continue
after this incident tanko is left to sob
uncontrollably in the yard as the rest
of the family returns in inside the
house the only one left to keep a
devastated tenko company is his dog
monchan but unfortunately for monchan
this emotionally charged moment of
sadness and despair and anger triggers
something within tenko his Quirk is
Decay and because tenko was hugging his
dog at the time monchan's body suddenly
disintegrates into a bloody mess little
tenko is shocked by this he has never
used the K before and he has no idea
what's going on he thinks that monchan
may have been attacked by a villain and
so when his sister Hannah comes out to
apologize for throwing him under the bus
tanko reaches out to her for help but as
soon as he touches his sister the same
thing that happened to monchan and
happens to her tenko's mom and
grandparents then also come out to see
what's happening and even though tenko
doesn't actually touch them he happens
to be down on all fours and touching the
ground when they come out because he was
touching the the ground his Decay
suddenly spreads from the ground onto
his mother and grandparents and all
three of them share the same brutal fate
as Hana and monchan finally when tenko's
father comes out to see what's going on
he too is killed by Decay but with one
major difference the deaths of the other
members of his family were not
intentional but when tenko sees his
father he truly snaps he intentionally
approaches his father touches his face
and kills him he wanted revenge against
his father for everything that his
father had put him through and he
willfully destroys his father and the
house that his father built with his
newly manifested Quirk after he killed
his entire family and destroyed his home
young tanko wandered around the city
aimlessly clearly shell-shocked and
deeply traumatized but even though he
was just a five-year-old kid who was
obvious see in need of assistance no one
tried to help him no hero or random
passerby tried to figure out what
happened to this kid they all seemed
freaked out by his appearance and they
just wanted to go about their normal
business the one who noticed the boy and
took him in was of course all for one
himself and with the help of Dr ujiko he
groomed tenko into becoming the villain
known as tomura shigaraki but is it a
coincidence that all for one just seemed
to suddenly stumble upon young tenko
shimura In This Moment Of Crisis is it a
coincidence that tenko's Quirk suddenly
manifested shortly after he was dropped
off at home by that mysterious man no
those were not coincidences tenkoshimura
was born quirkless and that is why his
Quirk did not appear until he was
already past five years old the reason
why young tenko was already on all for
one's radar at that young age is his
connection to Nana shimura tenko's
grandmother and all for one's sworn
enemy all for one wanted to mess with
Nana's family and so he was probably
keeping an eye on them for a while he
saw that tenko had serious issues with
his father and that he was a quirkless
boy who desperately wanted to become a
hero all for one also knew that he
wanted to find a new vessel sometime in
the future and a quirkless boy like
tenko was the perfect candidate someone
who is set to inherit all the many
different quirks that all for one
possesses including the all-for-one
Quirk itself probably needs to be born
quirkless we already know this to be the
case with one for all those who have a
quirk and inherit One for All Die Young
because their body burns out but those
who are quirkless and then inherit one
for all can live a full life like
almight did since all for one and one
for all share a special connection and
since one for all was literally created
by all for one it is likely that all for
one shares this characteristic with one
for all being quirkless is better on top
of that the immense hatred that was
growing inside of young tenko due to the
abuse he suffered at the hands of his
father made him the perfect candidate to
inherit not only all for one but also
one for all for many generations the
villain all for one has been trying to
steal the Quirk one for all but he
always failed because one for all has to
be transferred to another user willingly
at some point all for one concluded that
only someone with an immense amount of
hatred and willpower inside them is
capable of stealing one for all and so
he groomed tenko shimura from the young
age of five to become that type of
villain I'm like 99.9 sure that the
shigaraki was born querqua's Theory will
be confirmed in the manga very soon
which is why I've talked about it a few
times here on the channel as far as I'm
concerned this theory is true and we're
just waiting on final confirmation by
horikoshi but I know what you're
thinking how is all of this stuff about
shigaraki being quirkless related to
Deku there is another very popular
Theory out there which states that Deku
wasn't actually born quirkless he had a
quirk but it was secretly stolen from
him by all for one when he was still a
baby and because he was so young when it
happened Deku doesn't even know that he
ever had it this Theory stems from the
fact that deku's childhood doctor the
one who told him that he was born
quirkless in the first place just
happened to be none other than Dr ujiko
a villain who has worked directly with
all for one for many decades and who is
notorious for stealing and copying the
quirks of others when you really think
about it choosing ujiko in particular as
deku's childhood doctor so early in the
story was a very deliberate decision by
horikoshi and it's certainly possible
that he made this decision in order to
foreshadow a big reveal in the future
the reveal that Deku wasn't born
quirkless after all I mean initially we
all just believed the doctor's story
Deku has two joints in his spinky toes
instead of one which is an indication
that he is among the 20 of people who
don't have quirks the idea here is that
humans don't need a second joint in
their pinky toe it is a relic of an
earlier stage in our Evolution and so
those people who are further Rob The
evolutionary chain will only have one
pinky toe joint and they will have a
quirk while those who are quirkless
still have two pinky toe joints at least
that's how I interpreted this whole
thing but I am definitely not an
evolutionary biologist I think of it as
kind of like the concept that we don't
actually need our wisdom teeth anymore
we needed them back with humans ate raw
meats and other harder foods but this
was a very long time ago and so these
extra teeth are now just evolutionary
Leftovers about a third of people today
are born completely without wisdom teeth
so they are said to be further evolved
than those who still have them and yeah
all of this made sense at first the
doctor shows Deku an X-ray of his foot
he shows him that he has two joints in
his pinky and this means that he was
born worthless but obviously once we
learned the true identity of deku's
doctor things got a lot more complicated
this is a guy who made it his mission to
find powerful quirks so that all for one
could steal them he and all for one
literally ran an orphanage for kids with
powerful quirks who were being raised as
backup vessels for all for one in case
tomurashigaraki didn't work out this is
not the type of guy who should be
trusted on this subject what if the
correlation between pinky toe joints and
quirklessness isn't actually what it
appears to be we can assume that this
idea does exist in the world of mha
because when the doctor says that Deku
was born quirkless due to the fact that
he has two joints in his pinky toe
deku's mom doesn't really challenge him
since she knows how much becoming a hero
means to Deku we can assume that she
would challenge this logic unless she
herself believed it to be true unless
she had something to hide but more on
that later and maybe it is true that the
vast majority of people with two pinky
toe joints don't have a quirk but what
if there are exceptions what if some
children with two joints on their pinky
toes do have quirks but these children
are just rare this is is something that
the general public may not even know
about because it's so rare but someone
like oojiko a doctor who has been at the
Forefront of Quirk research for over 100
years would certainly know about this
rare occurrence we can't forget that
ujiko actually has a quirk that slows
down his aging process so he's been
alive for over a hundred years at this
point in time and if this is the case if
some children who have two pinky toe
joints do have quirks then stealing
these quirks is literally The Perfect
Crime Fujiko is a doctor who works with
hundreds of children he finds those rare
ones who have two joints and a quirk and
he steals that Quirk with all for one's
help without the child ever noticing
because the child has two joints
everyone just assumes that he or she was
always quirkless and no one ever
suspects ujiko of any wrongdoing if he
can steal the Quirk before it even
manifests or before the child is old
enough to remember it manifesting then
the child will never know that they had
a quirk in the first place in it's
actually the Perfect Crime so is it
possible that Deku was one of those rare
children with two joints and a quirk and
ujiko and all for one stole his Quirk
before he even knew he had it did
horikoshi foreshadow this massive reveal
way back in chapter one of the story
it's definitely possible although it's
not necessary for the plot and if Deku
really was just born quirkless it
wouldn't make the story any worse it
would just make the fact that his
childhood doctor happened to be the
villain ujiko a really big coincidence I
mean bitcoincidences do happen in real
life but on the off chance that Deku was
born with a quirk what would his Quirk
be it could be his father's Quirk which
is fire breathing his mother's Quirk
which was the telekinetic ability to
pull small objects towards yourself with
her mind or some combination of the two
a popular theory is that Deku originally
had some form of pyrokinesis the ability
ability to generate and manipulate fire
with your mind so it's a combination of
his mother's telekinetic work and his
father's fire breathing but much more
powerful than both of them put together
imagine being able to set an entire
building on fire just by looking at it
or producing and controlling Flames from
your own body and from anywhere else
that you may want to that would be an
extremely overpowered Quirk and just the
kind of Quirk that both ujiko and all
for one would be extremely interested in
but there is also another option which
is related to ujiko's own Theory Quirk
Singularity there are quirks that appear
as a result of extremely rare mutations
and they are completely different from
the quirks of the user's own parents
they are also usually much more powerful
and much more difficult to control which
is where the Quirk Singularity Theory
comes in Quirk Singularity Theory claims
that such rare mutations occur because
quirks keep evolving and becoming
stronger with each pass generation and
eventually they will become too strong
for their users bodies to handle them
which will lead to widespread chaos and
destruction Aries Quirk rewind is an
excellent example of this phenomenon her
extremely powerful Quirk Bears no
resemblance to either of her parents
quirks and it is far stronger and far
more dangerous than the quirks of other
people in her family obviously the idea
that deku's real Quirk could have been a
rare mutation leaves the door wide open
for speculation about what his original
Quirk might be and one popular Theory
out there is the theory that shigaraki's
Quirk Decay the one that all for one
secretly gave him on the day that he
dropped him off at his family home
actually belonged to Deku Deku was the
original owner of Decay but it was
stolen from him when he was just a baby
and given to shigaraki soon after now
because shigaraki is around 5 years
older than Deku and because shiraki
manifested Decay when he was 5 years old
if the okay was deku's original Quirk
then it must have been stolen from him
when he was still just a newborn as we
know quirks usually manifest at some
point before the age of four but there
are people like the famous luminescent
baby who manifested their quirks almost
immediately after being born if Deku had
Decay and it began to manifest when he
was still just a newborn and if fujika
was there in the hospital at the time of
his birth then ujiko and all for one
could have stolen Decay from Deku when
he was just a baby and Deku would have
no way of knowing that he ever had a
quirk as I mentioned earlier it would
have been the perfect crime and no one
would have been the wiser there are even
theories that deku's parents may have
asked all for one to remove deku's Quirk
because it was so dangerous and
uncontrollable and so he did them a
favor like he did to ayama's parents
when he agreed to give their quirkless
son a new Quirk but as we know all for
one demanded Allah lot in return from
the aoyamas and perhaps he also demanded
something big from deku's parents maybe
the real reason why we still haven't met
deku's dad is because he is working off
his death to all for one by doing his
bidding somewhere abroad according to
the darkest theory of all baby deck who
accidentally killed his own father when
Decay manifested much like Eddie
accidentally killed her father using
rewind deku's mom then begged all for
one and ujiko to save her son by taking
away his dangerous Quirk and she later
told him that his father Works abroad in
order to spare him from the terrible
truth that he accidentally killed his
own father when he was just a baby all
of these theories are intriguing and
that last one is deliciously dark but it
also seems kind of hard to believe that
someone like Deku the hero who wants to
save everyone and preserve the Integrity
of the hero Society would happen to have
a quirk that destroys everything and
everyone that it comes into contact with
it would be very ironic that said it
would be crazy if during the final
battle Deku learns that The Quirk which
shigaraki has been using to kill so many
innocent people was actually his own
original Quirk this kind of Revelation
would be truly heartbreaking for Deku
and it would make for some amazing
Shonen final battle drama what do you
guys think was shigaraki born quirkless
did Deku have a quirk that was stolen by
uchiko in all for one when he was a baby
was Deku the original user of
shigaraki's Decay let me know down below
if you're looking for something to watch
next don't ignore my video on all 20
quirks in class 1a it explains every
quirk in great detail and includes all
the latest updates and upgrades as of
the final Arc in the story don't miss it
link is on screen and in the description
don't forget to like And subscribe and
until next time see ya space Cowboys